hello and welcome to this video or
pendulum with my opponent and what is he
doing he 600 crab Jim and it should be a
good advance friendship with the knight
on c6 it's a bit tough to believe see
going to Castle queenside Crowley No
I believe this is a fairly standard way
of playing against this kind of setups
if I play b5 now is that an idea okay
let's just threaten b5 no that's okay
has to make some sort of concession
probably be six
yeah okay interesting yeah that that's a
funny one
okay so I could just take it that
wouldn't be bad in fact that it's quite
okay right and then rupee one I should
be a good position for white
yeah that should be good just feel the
weaker eat six fields a week and
probably play Queen d7 and then
something like 23 and C form should be a
nice initiative for to see going to do
Bishop d6 something I don't know takes
Bishop do you know what is he doing
takes than Queen d5 or what's the point
anyways he voice is some part of this
position anyway so let's play it I mean
he has to take what what does there's no
other move if I get to we cannot play
like a co-op g8 or something I go or c5
b 5 and made its it's not going to work
so it has to be the same
[Music]
yeah if I take and he takes with the
pawn that is not too bad it's not so bad
now know that that I did not play where
I guess
hmm Jim uncertain but I didn't want to
trade that sir she's just so lame oh wow
okay
still expected rupiah I mean from a from
a structure point of view I'm not
unhappy with this okay I cannot take of
course but just just this should be
quite okay my king is save and I have
rookie C 1 and B 5 coming I should be
fine
Jim what can I not take I don't know
probably I can take really I have to
check on a six ah
I completely overlooked that 100 that is
a that is a very stupid oversight that's
annoying
that's very annoying really yeah I can
take here right come I have to and free
the bishop at the same time now
and as a chequered check first think
later check now there we could do you
one almost works
okay now I'm not not really happy with
this game that is a really weird opening
and did not really get all that much so
I'm fairly happy with this okay I am
that's actually true we am I don't need
to take there immediately
I can't castle first of course because
there's this idea but this is a problem
you know okay I'll be ship c6 is not too
bad its power part of this position type
so yeah maybe what did I do wrong
it's really interesting taking no so
this is just this should just be better
right
I Queenie - of course and then c4 that's
a lot better this is a real temple not
Queen d3 and then then I can do this or
whatever mp5 or with a king here this is
an advantage yeah okay so this this was
a problem and here thought just rook e8
is fine rook e8 Bishop d6 and black is
fine after that I think I'm I'm better I
have the better structure and my king is
also long-term safer and Here I am
taking on a7 was a bit cheeky I mean it
is also pretty clear that I'm better
with normal moves I'm a bit surprised
that the engine is 1.6 in my favour that
sits high I didn't think it was that
much just by normal moves and this is
probably not a good idea I completely
missed can be several just really
embarrassing now Luke G form and black
is bad I am
no I don't think I would have been able
to defend us really it looks so odd like
now he's got this attacking moves and I
have this this stupid bishop and he he
just basically blundered it away here
with the Queen would create sex it's a
double question mark why okay there was
a +9 and it's just plus 4 okay yeah so
now that wasn't well played in
particular Bishop takes a 7s bit
ridiculous if you don't see that I mean
I honestly overlooked Queen to be 7
which is very stupid to overlook and
then I shouldn't take I just play like
here display normal moves and be better
here b5 for example we have those easy
moves a4 a5 Luke c1 while it takes a
while until black is threatening
something just takes a while okay guys
thanks for watching